anyone entering this country illegally
will be detained and swiftly removed
the illegal migration Bill if passed
could detain up to 15
000 children seeking safety on Britain's
Shores
to Ali this is bad news he came to the
UK from Iran as a teenager and claims
he's seen it all but says this bill goes
too far almost lost everything I had in
my life you know like family home
friends everything I had detaining
children is like something beyond my
imagination and so a coalition of
doctors and medical leaders are
demanding an urgent meeting with top
government ministers to address their
concerns for Asylum seeking children we
know that children who are detained are
likely to suffer incredibly poor health
in the long term including things such
as PTSD adverse mental health adverse
physical health as well
the Prime Minister has previously said
children cannot be the exception to the
bill as in doing so could create a pull
factor in migration but not everyone
agrees and what this bill will say to
them is you're not welcoming in our
country we want to lock you up we don't
care if you're desperate if you're
traumatized and we think it shows
cold-heartedness it shows a deep lack of
compassion
the home office however in a statement
says otherwise
while this legislation gives the Home
Secretary the power to remove an
unaccompanied child under 18 from the UK
we've amended the bill to make clear
that this will only be exercised in very
limited circumstances such as for the
purposes of reunion with a parent or
removing someone to their safe home
country
regardless of how rare these detentions
may be doctors are concerned these
already vulnerable children could face
harm rather than help summer Chowdhury
Sky News